[Aplausos]
toda mi vida me encantaban los deportes
a los 2 años empecé con la anotación a
los 4 años practica karate y finalmente
a los 10 médica 100% a practicar fútbol
el fútbol es mi vida lo que más me gusta
es que es un juego en equipo durante el
partido tiene que hablar con tus
compañeros para poder llegar al arco y
anotar un gol
mi mayor sueño era convertirme en
jugador profesional jugar en el equipo
de mis amores el independiente del valle
y algún día ser seleccionado nacional y
quién quita poder alzar la copa del
mundo
era la meta que más tenía el sueño que
lo quería realizar y todo apuntaba a que
iba en buen camino jugaba en las menores
independiente del valle y estaba próxima
a lograr mi sueño
me acuerdo en un entrenamiento cuando
tuve una pequeña molestia en la rodilla
tuve que parar en ese momento y en el
doctor me dolía bastante no podía sentar
la pierna cuando llegue el doctor me
dijo
tengo que hacerte unas radiografías para
ver qué está pasando
me fui hice las radiografías volví y al
momento en que le indique la radiografía
al doctor me quedo mirando
lo que me dijo
cambiaría mi vida
me acuerdo que me quedo viendo en los
ojos y me dijo carlos
su cartílago está desprendido no podrás
volver a jugar fútbol probablemente
hasta no puedas volver a correr
en ese momento mi vida se fue a mi mundo
se fue abajo quien me acaba de decir que
después de tantos años
entrenando y entrenando y entrenando
para cumplir una amistad de un día para
el otro ya no lo podría hacer ya no lo
podría volver a realizar
me acuerdo que me operaron
salió todo bien exitosamente y entré en
etapa de recuperación
en la rehabilitación
pese a que yo me estaba recuperando yo
no veía mayor mejoría
me sentía pésimo
después de estar toda mi vida saltando
corriendo ahora tenían que estar las 24
horas del día postrado en mi cama sin
hacer nada
fue un duro golpe para mí
todo esto pasó en el verano del año
pasado
pasó el tiempo de vacaciones y tenía que
volver a clases y volver a clases
era lo peor encima más que no me gustaba
las clases de física química y
matemáticas
ahora ya no podría ni siquiera moverme
un poco
llega el primer día en muletas porque
prácticamente no podría no podía doblar
mi rodilla a 10 grados
estar encerrado en un aula era lo peor
para mí
y a mí lo único que me importaba en el
fotos
yo decía no algún día me voy a recuperar
y voy a volver a las canchas yo no le
creí al doctor
yo me enfocaba solo en el fútbol en mi
recuperación y en volver a las canchas
no me importaba ni mi familia ni mis
amigos sobre esa meta
me acuerdo que ya entramos en etapa de
exámenes pruebas
durante este proceso o una clase que me
llamó la atención
la clase de emprendimiento se respiraba
un aire distinto era algo diferente algo
que despertó mi curiosidad de nuevo pero
ya no lo aceptaba no yo me voy a
recuperar y volver a las canchas
me acuerdo que tuvimos una un examen de
emprendimiento yo no había estudiado no
sabía nada
no había escrito nada en esa prueba y
conforme mis compañeros acababan la
prueba le entregaban y salían al recreo
yo fue el último ahí con mi profesor
y dije ahora qué hago para que no se dé
cuenta que hago para que vea que no
escrito nada aparte de mi nombre claro
cuando le fui a entregar la prueba le
hice un poco la conversa y entre unas
cuantas preguntas hubo una que desde ese
instante cambiaría mi vida totalmente me
acuerdo que le pregunten profe
como uno puede encontrar su verdadera
pasión como uno puede encontrar la razón
por la que está aquí en este mundo esa
respuesta fue increíble me dijo todas
esas respuestas que esto estás buscando
están dentro de ti si tú quieres saber
el por qué estás aquí en este mundo
busca dentro no busques bueno tú te
conoces más que nada todo eso que tú
estás buscando está adentro bajo quien
acaba de decir me acuerdo que salí al
patio con mis compañeros me senté en el
graderío y me puse a pensar
a ver a ver carlos que es lo último que
te está a vos que te está gustando
qué es lo que te ha despertado una nueva
curiosidad
emprendimiento por ahí puede que esté el
camino me acuerdo que ese mismo día
llegué a mi casa abrí mi computador me
puse investigar más sobre el mundo de
los negocios
quedé fascinado me gustó bastante me
llamaba demasiado la atención y dije
mi abuelita tiene sus decoraciones ella
se cuadros y pinturas porque no
formalizar su trabajo y hacer una
empresa con ella
me acuerdo que fui a abrir la puerta de
mi cuarto y les conté a mi abuelita esta
asombrosa idea
hicimos un logo un eslogan una página
web y actualmente seguimos seguimos en
ese proyecto
pasó el tiempo y esta nueva pasión
seguía creciendo empecé a asistir a
conferencias empecé a leer muchos libros
antes pero un libro para mí era lo peor
me daba miedo no me gustaba
y ahora es uno de esos pasatiempos que
más disfruto
este año se me presentaría una
oportunidad increíble
junior achievement es una fundación que
despierta la visión emprendedora en
jóvenes estudiantes como nosotros
era la oportunidad perfecta para aplicar
mis conocimientos aprendidos y para
aprender más sobre el emprendimiento
y me acuerdo la primera capacitación que
nos dieron y nos dijeron tienen que
hacer un producto que sea innovador un
innovador quien es exáctamente innovador
para mí innovador era algo relacionado
netamente con la tecnología
ideas locas cómo crear una computadora
que funcionara solo con la mente cosas
de ese estilo
estuvimos un mes casi
preguntándonos qué producto hacer hasta
que tuvimos una reunión nos sentamos
todos los miembros de la empresa a
discutir y hablar sobre qué producto
teníamos que hacer y nos acordamos que
teníamos la posibilidad de cambiar el
mundo y hacer algo positivo por las
personas
entre muchas ideas cómo crear un
producto ante cosas o crear una goma
elástica para personas no videntes
decidimos crear un chaleco para niños
con autismo
best friend
best friend es un chaleco con
estimulación sensorial y peso el peso
está colocado estratégicamente en cada
bolsillo del chaleco esto ayuda a los
niños porque les da una mayor contención
un mayor registro interno qué es esto
del registro interno el registro interno
es la falta del control de sus
sensaciones y nosotros les damos esto
les aportamos esto porque el chaleco da
la sensación de un abrazo
y en la parte delantera tenemos la
estimulación sensorial que es la felpa
que ayuda a que los niños estén en
confianza con el chaleco porque se
asemeja a su oso de peluche
actualmente soy gerente de marketing de
la empresa musk una jota la empresa que
me enseñó que innovar no es solamente
crear tecnología nueva innovar es
encontrar una necesidad encontrar un
problema y solucionarlo
todos se preguntarán por qué dije que no
debería estar aquí eso es lo que pensaba
un año antes de encontrar mi verdadero
sueño
recuerden que emprender no significa
solo iniciar un negocio o crear una
empresa
emprender
es tener un reino y luchar por hacerlo
realidad pero nunca se cierren o cierren
sus mentes
siempre estén dispuestos a que vengan
nuevas cosas
en mi caso la vida todo que dan un
fuerte golpe para que yo entendiera cuál
es el verdadero motivo por el que estoy
aquí
recuerden que el éxito no se mide en
cuánto dinero factores
el éxito se mide en el tamaño de la
sonrisa de tus clientes cuando les pones
feliz cuando les das tu producto y se
ponen contentos
esta es mi vida
y así fue como pasé de ser futbolista a
ser todo un emprendedor muchas gracias